so two weeks ago I did a story asking is
the United States a failed state we
failed on a medical response to the
pandemic health systems falling apart
corruption no trust in government are we
a failed state we are now finding
ourselves asking is the u.s. a first
world country in light of the completely
absent leadership as federal from
federal government as protests raged
nationally over out-of-control policing
as it is seen by millions and millions
of people and in addition to the
protests literal dumpster fires around
the White House as the White House sits
in darkness with Trump tweeting as you
have violence police attacking
protesters protesters attacking police
we're seeing media get shot with rubber
bullets and attacked not just physically
but ideologically for their presence at
the unrest Caitlin rust a reporter for
an NBC affiliate station in Louisville
Kentucky was fired upon by police Friday
night covering a live street protest
that was going on CNN reporter Omar
Jimenez was arrested while covering
protests over the weekend subsequently
released it was chalked up to confusion
by police about who he was he happens to
be black last night
Cleveland Police said no media would be
allowed in any of the downtown area as
protests raged it's not even clear that
that's legal to do this concept of a
first world country comes from the Cold
War it has some implicit biases but
really now what we're talking about is
the westernized developed nations of the
world so look at what we have corrupt
incompetent leadership increasing
attacks on media by government and by
police growing unrest between police and
the public
a judiciary system that has two tiers
one for the rich and one for the poor
we've got rampant cronyism and
corruption lack of access to quality
health care for a huge portion of the
country a failing education system our
response to the corona virus pandemic
has completely failed compared to other
developed nations infrastructure is not
crumbling but we are way behind where we
should be for a country of our wealth
look
our airports to some around the world
look at our highways to those in many
parts of the world and meanwhile our
president is sitting in a white and a
darkened White House sometimes in the
bunker below it on Friday night as DC
literally burns providing no leadership
no words of de-escalation nothing other
than self aggrandizement and threats to
protesters so I'm not literally saying
we are no longer a first world country
but more and more we're reacting to
events the way a less advanced country
would I want to hear from you about this
I will have more about it upcoming let
me know your thoughts on Twitter at D
Pakman remember to make sure you are
subscribed for free to the daily one
hour-long David Pakman show podcast on
whatever podcasting app you use